There's something else we need to talk
about before you start writing code.
Go ahead and download the starter code
project for my favorite movies and
then open up the info.plist file.
I believe it's located in
supporting files > info.plist.
Remember how we had to modify
the info.plist file in the image
request app?
This accounted for
images that used HTTP instead of HTTPS.
Well, as of now the movie database
also relies on HTTP to actually
make some of its request for
images and such.
And to adhere to Apple's ATS standards,
this just won't cut it, so
we've made some changes
to the info.plist file.
And we'll collapse out the at
transport security settings.
And let's just collapse all these so
you can see everything.
Instead of allowing arbitrary loads,
like we did in the image request app,
and remember, this looked like we'd
go here, allow arbitrary loads, yes.
So this property, we've gotten rid of,
we don't need this property anymore.
To do this, we've used
the exception domains dictionary,
which in itself contains dictionaries
for each domain that the API uses.
And for each domain,
we can specify that we want to allow
it to use insecure HTTP loads.
Now I know some of these key value
pairs you haven't seen before, but
it's not really important that I
get into all of them right now.
The only one that I want to point
out is NSIncludesSubdomains.
This key provides a boolean that says
whether or not you want settings of
a domain, say like cloudfront.net
to apply to all of it's subdomains.
A subdomain is an extension to
a domain name that's used to organize
resources together.
For instance,
udacity.com is a domain, and
it has the subdomain review.udacity.com.
On review.udacity.com,
you'll find webpages, images, and
other resources that are related
to Udacity project reviews.
So if we were to set
NSIncludesSubdomains to yes for
udacity.com in our info.plist file, that
means we'd want to extend any settings
of udacity.com to all its subdomains,
like review.udacity.com,
discussions.udacity.com and any others.
I just wanted to make you aware that
these properties have been updated for
my favorite movies.
If you want to read more
about these properties,
the ones that you can use for ATS, I've
posted a link in the instructor notes.